so hey everyone my name is Yvonne I'm a
grad student at UC Berkeley studying
computer science in
based group so my talk today is called
knowing what do you see let's talk about
front end consistency so as you may have
noticed it's a little bit inconsistent
no pun intended with the abstracts but
it's so in a similar domain and another
point that differs is that I am no
longer a first-year grass you'd have
probably entered my second year so this
work is some research that my group has
been focusing on so anything that I say
that's useful that's definitely shared
results and anything that's wrong I take
complete credit so before I get started
and since we're a pretty small crowd I
just want to get a sense of how many of
you identify as a front-end engineer
great and back-end engineers cool Wow so
how many of you have heard of acid
transactions hold your hand up if you
know what multi version concurrency
control is Wow okay all right this is a
tougher crowd than I expected I thought
I could just say things cool so I guess
as you have sort of probably guess from
my questions this talk will straddle
both sides of the different fields and
hopefully by the end of the top you will
gain appreciation for the other side
because as I suspect you probably don't
know too much about if your back-end
about front end in front end about as
much about back-end on average so what
do I actually mean by front-end
consistency intuitively it's basically
the same as the dictionary definition so
conformity in the application of
something typically that which is
necessary for the sake of logic accuracy
and fairness so for our case with
visualization we actually care more
about logic and accuracy and let's take
a look at some examples to sort of get
an intuitive sense of what I mean
usually it's fine when I open my
facebook i don't really expect in
particular to see my ads show up with
the news feed and when I open my Twitter
it's okay that I don't see the media
before I see my friends tweet I can get
us so vague sense of what's going on but
sometimes you do have expected
and you don't see what do you expect so
how could this happen imagine that
you're driving through the middle of
seemingly nowhere and you're desperately
trying to find a dinner place and this
thing shows up for a good half minute it
could be a pretty frustrating experience
and let's take a look at what actually
happens step by step that caused this to
show up so here's a pretty simple time
diagram with the user the front end and
the back end so the user opens the
application the front end makes a
request to get the map and get the pins
however the mapped it is a little bit
larger in terms of data size and takes
longer to load so the pin comes back
first the app renders it the user sees
this view and then for the time
afterwards until the maps arrive it's
just going to be like this which could
potentially be a little bit problematic
and we call this the yellow range
slightly inconsistent so many of the
front-end engineer sitting in the room
may already have a lot of solutions that
this is such like why don't we just
block it etc so please bear with me
we're just getting started on the
appetizer here i'm sure the problem will
get a little bit more interesting as we
go but before we even go there let me
just need a numerate through how common
this problem is and oh by the way we're
going to name this anomaly reordering
because as we see the map arrived out of
water per the request ordered so another
simple example just a few days ago I was
trying to print some posters on
walgreens and I was expecting my picture
to show up drag it over and then print
it and be done with it but I didn't see
anything so that was really confusing
because I didn't know whether I should
wait or refresh so I'm sure many of you
could identify having use terribly
design applications like this and this
anomaly we call barring delays because
there was no signal for what was going
on so the anomalies we've seen so far it
is rendering and varying delays so as
the front-end engineers city in the room
we can just simply block and show both
of the data results that they come back
and for varying delays at a spinner
problem solved however the real world
scenarios actually get a little bit more
complicated so let's take a look at this
visualization dashboard
so there are this map region which
corresponds to the different
visualizations we see on the bottom and
the user could choose to zoom in so here
we zoom into the African region and we
expect some visualizations to update so
how many of you have noticed that there
were updates or there haven't been
updates it was pretty subtle right again
the UI UI front of engineers who say oh
this is just terribly designed there's
no feedback that that is definitely true
but this is basically just pointing out
how as a user you might be unclear
whether regions current weather data
corresponds to and so in this specific
example shared by region loaded first
customer distribution loaded second and
sales actually never refreshed so the
time diagram as seen before is sort of
the user zooms in the front end issues
multiple requests and then they arrive
with some different delays and so in
this yellow region some things are out
of sync and if there's no sort of
feedback mechanism you would mean that
the users looking at the wrong data and
drawing the wrong conclusions we call
this anomaly mistaken correspondences so
so far I be naming the anomalies so I
can refer back to them once we actually
have a good way to sort of deal with
them all and again some of you may say
oh like this complicated example you
show is actually really simple because
we can just prefetch everything and my
push back to that is sometimes it's not
all possible right imagine the user just
selecting some arbitrary regions because
they have very complex analysis needs
with the cases like this it's very hard
to pre-compute all the data and just
squeeze it all to the front end so
that's probably not going to be the
perfect solution some of you might ask
why couldn't we just split into grids
and then that way we have a finite
number of requests that's a pretty much
manageable but this limits the
flexibility of how the user could
interact with the UI so in this case the
user can only select multiples of the
grid so here we see a very canonical
example of trade-offs that we deal with
every day like functionality versus
performance
some of you might also ask why couldn't
we just ask that back under engineers to
make things run faster like with that's
always the perfect solution right it's
none of our front of engineers business
to deal with any of this crap so the
reasons actually pretty tough as many of
you have left so I imagine this
conversation may have happened sometime
in the past so the first issue is that
the server compute time might just take
a while because if you're doing
aggregation over one terabyte of data
which is no longer like a big number for
us entering this big data era this is
really hard to fix and then there could
potentially be cache misses because that
is not really popular analyzed among
different people and we've seen that
this is a very tough engineering
challenge their bazillion of new
databases that's created every day just
to tackle like application specific
needs for instance amazon dynamo as an
example and that requires a lot of
engineering power so this is not
something we can just trivial you say to
a single backend engineer here solve my
problem you date and there's actually
more subtle issues where it's completely
out of your control because the
application has the user has a slow
internet connection and in that case it
doesn't matter how fast your servers
compute the bottlenecks at the client so
you will still have to deal with this
inconsistency issues and we're still
there are actually more anomalies that
are a little bit more problematic than
just server and delays so let's take a
look at this real-time interaction and
I'm sure many of you are aware real-time
is starting to replace big data as this
new hot thing everyone's chasing and
it's only a matter of time before we
start extensively using visualizations
that are a real time so actually this
morning I was looking at my uber app and
tracking my driver because the rain was
peering and I couldn't make the short
two-minute walk over so and it was late
and I was so confused because I kept on
looking across the street and there was
a driver waving at me right in front of
me and I was like this can't be the
driver this can't be the driver because
ubert
me it's still three minutes away so
that's another example where the real
time aspect of the visualizations
actually really important and come to
our like day to day lives but anyhow
let's take a look at this example where
imagine your stock trader and this is
some tix that's being updated over time
and you're interested in the region
between 60 and 25 and you select this
but and you see some average dividend
that's calculated based on this tick and
immediately afterwards though or some
real time that are being updated and it
becomes slightly unclear what this new
dividend is being computed as does they
actually include the yellow region or
did it stick with the green one that we
selected before so this is a nominee of
unclear selection that's caused by
real-time interactions another example
which is a little bit more subtle is
that imagine as you're doing the
selection that data started updating and
your selection actually finished after
the data updated as we know that as
humans we don't really have like one
millisecond response times as we expect
all our servers to have so in this case
it becomes a little bit problematic
whether you actually selected 25 to 55
or this new region that's a like 40 to
60 so as you can see this consistency
problem gets pretty hairy as we start
giving more and more richer
functionalities so in this case it's
actually a wrong selection and one last
example before we move on so here we
have an incremental visualization where
you slowly select the bar charts and the
visualizations supposed to update as it
goes so the orange bars correspondence
came back first and then the second one
for the blue came back so some of you
may have noticed that some issue
happened right here where there was an
overlap so if the user were just to look
at the final state of the visualization
they may not realize oh that was
actually orange dot below it so this
anomaly we call overwritten marks but
some of you sitting down there might be
like wait a second so I think a
synchrony could be my problem but this
is totally just a layout issue right
like how is this even related to
consistency so
so again like I am mentioning this to
sort of include the breadth of
consistency problems can cover and you
can definitely try to brush this aside
as a layout issue and solving another
way but as we probably all experience
most engineering problems aren't
clear-cut bucketed and I would say that
this is definitely a layout issue if
it's a single selection and you're
updating everything all at once but
because here there's a delay and you're
not seeing all of that at all at once so
this could be treated as a consistency
issue because it's actually like that
are changing over time so we sort of
found all of the consistency bugs that
could possibly exist and there's
probably more so we've seen reordering
rain delays and concurrent updates so
this is a good point to sort of step
back and say what is what do you
actually mean by consistency where
engineers here stop giving me these like
fluffy word the bad news however is that
consistency is in the eyes of the
beholder and this is not just because
we're dealing with the fluffy UI for
those back-end engineers you probably
know that consistency the word is not
really well defined even in acid
transactions the joke goes and I do not
claim this to be completely true that
the sea was created so that the acronym
sounds cool and the reason is that
consistency is dependent on application
semantics let's take a look at example
in vanilla systems so you have a
database and it's a for financial
services and your checking account must
have balance greater than zero right if
it's below zero is inconsistent and if
you have a credit card you only require
the balance to be greater than a sort of
negative amount so in that case if it's
you know slightly negative is still
consistent so this is an example of when
consistency is dependent on application
semantics I see some of you are not
quite agreeing I would add the caveat
that the consistency in cap theorem is
well defined and it's a little bit
different from we're talking about and
I'm not going to go into the details I
only mission cap theorem so that you
guys know what I'm talking about so now
that we've sort of understood some of
the
cincy issues we see in the front end
some of you probably are still on
comments like why am I sitting here who
cares so I would argue that the first
group of people who care are the data
analyst so again as we've seen this
consistency issue is very relevant for a
data visualization especially
interactive data visualization over big
data so the analyst would be frustrated
if she doesn't know what states the UI
could be in at any point in time so you
imagine your text editor just randomly
giving you characters as you're typing
that must be frustrating I would imagine
that's what translates to for the visual
analysis case and then the data analysts
might propagate the problem up to the
front end engineer and say hey why don't
you fix this issue I'm really confused
the front-end engineer may design a ton
of callbacks and falling to a week other
we would normally recognize this
callback hell or they can say oh back on
the engineers go fix this problem for me
if everything's fast I don't have this
problem and we've discussed the limits
with that solution before and the worst
case actually is when the user doesn't
realize there was inconsistency so they
might draw the wrong conclusions this is
pretty terrible and so today we might
not be living in the ironman world yet
but as we've seen big data is starting
to sort of flow into all aspects of our
lives the future is now basically and we
see a ton of startups integrating very
fancy real-time dashboards that are very
complex looking all over the place tons
of startups so these startups are part
of our mission critical tasks day-to-day
tasks that are responsible for your
health your money and your policies so
hopefully I've convinced you by now that
this is actually a worthy problem that
we should all take a look at and there
are many very good engine in front of
engineering out there and there are a
lot of existing approaches to tackle
this problem to some extent so let's
take a look at some existing approaches
the first one is blocking so after the
user resumed
instead of updating things they're
synchronously let's just get rid of all
the all the visualization because
they're inconsistent right so let's wait
until all of the data has loaded and
then update all at the same time this is
okay right he helps us with the
increasing consistency but the
interactivity is pretty mad and the ease
of understanding is decent because you
know we're getting right when it's not
loading you know it's still processing
and the ease of programming is okay like
it's not as complicated as adding all
these widgets but you still need to have
quite a few callbacks etc to synchronize
your data results another example
another solution is using spinners so
after we perform the zoom the sales and
customer distributions starts to sort of
load and then when the customer
distribution arrives the spinner stops
great we know exactly what's going on
and we know that we shouldn't trust the
sales visualization so we wouldn't make
the wrong conclusions however I would
make the argument that spinners are
sometimes not enough so when we have
multiple zoom levels for instance here
once we zoom further in they're all
spinning so we basically get this binary
notion of is it up to date or is it not
up to date but we don't really know how
many steps forward it is and this could
potentially be a problem if you have a
very busy analyst who's just like
selecting things all the time and if
your server is really slow than ninety
percent of the time when you're
interacting with the visualization
everything will be spinning so that
would be a pretty bad user experience so
on this we argue is is ok for your
consistency because as we've mentioned
before it doesn't cover all the cases
the interactivity is okay because we can
see some partial results the ease of
understanding is once again just okay
because you could have your
visualizations being different states
but have the spinner running all the
same the same way and this is probably
not that easy to program because now you
have this like gazillion which is to
keep track of and they
could sort of work with each other in a
combinatorial way that you have to track
many different types of states another
solution is to use labeling so I I did
define sort of consistency as knowing
what the logic is or what the current
state of the UI is so why don't we just
label all of the visualizations we see
so here you're SAT setting lat is
negative 85 your ending long is like 180
etc us and when you zoom let's just
update all of these different
annotations so this this is okay because
it is perfectly consistent if you stare
at it it gives you all the information
you need and the interactivity is pretty
decent because you can get data as they
arrive however the issues that this is
not very easy to understand where you
essentially defeating the whole purpose
of visualization by adding on queries to
annotate these data when in reality we
should be using visual cues and
correspondences to actually show whether
that amines so this is an example of
when it's not that easy to understand
and it's probably not very easy to
program in a way that's similar to the
spinners but perhaps even more
challenging because you have to now deal
with a lot more layout issues and
annotations etc and at this point we
still haven't accounted for the
anomalies we've seen with the unclear
selection overwritten marks so it's not
perfect in terms of solving our problems
let's just take a quick review of the
design space before we start looking to
some potential options so in the
anything-goes approach consistency is
fat Interactive is great ease of
understanding is bad because we don't
know what's going on either programming
is great because that's essentially what
you get with JavaScript callback at just
writing vanilla JavaScript and then
these are the three cases that we
already discussed so at this point I've
probably lost the interest of most of
your you back and engineers it's like
this is not my problem just a lot of
like fun
why do I care I don't even need to make
things run fast as you have explained to
the people right but if we stare hard
enough at this problem it really begs
the question is this front engineering
or is it distributed systems because now
the front end has to deal with all these
issues of requests delays asynchrony
concurrency and consistency like these
are all the words that you here in like
distributed systems 101 or database 101
classes I think at the core of this
problem is that it's all just data
centric programming because most of
engineering some of you might disagree
is just piping data around so it's not
surprising that the front-end start to
look similar to the backend once we get
into these more complex visualizations
so my punch line is that the front end
is a database and with this perspective
we can solve a lot of the issues we've
seen previously the reasons that
database techniques have been dealing
with reordering for a very long time and
they can deal with reordering to bring
consistency and do this dick start
declaratively so let's take a look at
how exactly it could help us but before
I do that I want to sort of show this is
not some crazy talk based on someone
who's extremely biased who does research
and thinks about database all day long
and is actually agreed upon by a lot of
the very hip front-end libraries so the
first one is d3d three manipulates the
documents in a way that's very similar
to a sequel select project a project
joint pattern because of time limits I
won't go into the details of why exactly
it is but if you think about the select
all p and then the accident and enter
that's very similar to joints and
reactive xrx is or react etc you
probably have all heard feels very much
with the streams and iterators which are
very intrinsic to database
implementations ever since the 70s so
again this is sort of a programming
paradigm we're very familiar with in
distributed systems
and lastly there's the very recent
facebook relay which operates in a
matter that's very similar to cry
optimization where the data fetching
actually decides the where and the when
to the we're sorry the when and how to
fetch the data that's essentially what
traditionally data core data pray
optimization would do so hopefully by
now I've convinced you that there is
some merits and in looking at the front
end as a database and I'm not sort of
going crazy here you're making that
claim so let's step back a little and
think about how to use this newfound
perspective to help us deal with
inconsistency so for the remaining time
I have which is not too long we're going
to take a look at the detection of
inconsistencies and try to propose a
somewhat formal framework so that we can
capture all these issues in a more
systematic manner as opposed to looking
and saying it oh this doesn't make sense
to me pretty low baseline the next is
once we detect these issues how do we
prevent it from happening at the first
place there are two main approaches one
is that we just ensure consistency and
never have the users see anything that's
inconsistent or we can communicate the
inconsistency until the user look the
status is now correct yet just wait
sounds familiar to the systems people
this is a very similar to eventual
consistency so anyhow this is currently
going through pretty active development
and there could be some good ideas and
bad ideas and if I ever say anything
that you disagree with I'm more than
happy to hear your ideas and criticisms
and please talk to me afterwards or chat
me on Twitter so let's get started with
the detection formal framework so this
we i didn't mention at the front end
should be treated as a database and as
we know database come from a relational
model and let's take a look at exactly
how this would be interpreted as a query
so as the user is selecting a view one
we have the stream of mouse events where
the user mouse down we have the XY
position and
there's a mouse move and then further
mouse up so streams are could be also
cried in some extension of sequel this
has been actively research in the 90s is
called cql so there are a lot of
existing approaches to deal with streams
and in some sense stream surges a table
in time so it's not a very far stretch
to say that we can incorporate streams
into the relational model and then this
information is joined with the marks
that are underlying this visualization
so here we know that the view one has
rectangles of X Y is underneath the hood
essentially this is doing hit testing so
we get the results from the join of
these two tables and join up with the
base data which is essentially
simulating this back-end server request
where you say go fetch me this data
thats related to these data points and
then you get the results that's the
result of your query and you render this
to the front end now that we sort of see
how the interactions could be modeled as
a query over different tables let's
model the interaction a little bit
further as a transaction as most of you
probably know a transaction is the note
is a defined loosely as this notion of
executing a set of demand a commands
atomically without interference by other
transactions so and it's usually
identified by its reasoned rights to the
the data base underneath the hood so our
interpretation of the interaction is
that it's a read of the underlying
tables and it's a right of the UI when
it starts to render the data so there's
this parallel parallel of reading the UI
tables and writing to the UI stables and
this is pretty important to set up our
problem because without this notion of a
read and write we can't really establish
a very concrete notion of conflict so a
dataflow way of looking at this
relational / transactional system is
that the user issue through the
interaction which performs the read
which sends a request to the server like
to perform the query the join which gets
a result back and it's a right to the UI
which further renders the data to the
user and somewhere along the way
hopefully there are some confirmation of
the interaction so for instance when you
brush you can see your brush and that's
rendered immediately which is also
considered to be a right so that was a
little bit too abstract you're probably
missing all the fun animations and
visualizations we were seeing a lot of
earlier so let's take a look at account
a concrete example of conflict so again
very the same example as that we had
before as the user is clicking now on
the green part on this blue part I
couldn't read is a and you would have
this register of current interactions
which registers that the orange is so
active and when you click on the blue it
attempts to update something that is
written by the current active
interaction I transaction and because
there's a lock on it it's detected as a
conflict if you decide to overwrite this
conflict you would essentially end up
over writing or previous mark so this is
an example where we were able to use
this model to detect conflict on the
pixel level to find one of the anomalies
we mentioned before this is essentially
a right right conflict for those of you
who are familiar with database
distributed systems terms where there
are two interactions attempting to write
to the same pixels during their
execution there are of course other
types of conflicts as inspired from sort
of this conflict reasoning framework
which is a read/write and let's take a
look at how this maps to our previously
seen a streaming example so here when
the user does a selection as we
mentioned before that's a read on the
existing table however as the user was
doing performing this read and executing
the the results the Cray with the back
end there was actually a right on
something that was reading from so this
is a read/write conflict again we've
demonstrated how this model
has detected one of the anomalies we've
seen before the curious case with when
the human is involved in the loop is
that there's a right read conflict do to
the human latency so let's take a close
look at this example whereas the user
was interacting the data has been
updated so this is essentially when
there was a right whoops there was a
right immediately before the read and
this usually you don't see in systems as
much but is like intrinsic part of what
happens when you bring a human into the
loop is that we we don't have a response
like reaction time on the order of
milliseconds so when we decide to do
something and things update during the
pier that we're performing this read
it's actually a conflict as well so
hopefully by now I've convinced you that
using this framework we can fit all
these different anomalies we've seen
before into this detection framework and
with ten minutes left let me quickly
move on to how do we actually solve this
problem so the first is he is to ensure
consistency a technique that we've seen
is blocking which I argue is very
similar to what back and folks do for
locking and it's essentially locking on
the entire UI it's saying once you've
done this interaction no other
interactions that or transactions can
actually update the same UI so you're
just block there to wait so if we extend
this analogy to inspiration from systems
algorithms to more front-end techniques
we can imagine to have more granular
locks that way you don't prevent
interactions that doesn't actually
interfere with each other to happen
simultaneously the question is can we
draw more insights from algorithms from
systems concurrency and the answer is of
course yes the first one is interaction
constraints which draws inspiration from
database constraints let's take a look
at the anomaly we've seen before so here
we can make the statement that the piss
would only render if the maps have
rendered so you show the maps first
before you show the pin it's a very
declarative way of describing
what you want to achieve another thing
that's inspired from systems it's like
the crdt or lattice this line of
thinking is that you can merge the
update so you can avoid these conflicts
so here once we see that the blue is
attempting to update the orange instead
of rejecting the blues update which is a
little bit too aggressive we can say
let's make both of them transparent and
that way you can avoid a conflict by
addressing the issue here again this is
not a new technique the front end folks
probably use this day to day but the
point is to show how there's this very
close tie between systems thinking and
front-end designs another example is
actually inspired from multi version
concurrency control and the basic idea I
won't go into details of explaining what
this exactly does and this is a very
loose coupling it's an inspiration so
what a Maps 24 visualizations is that we
can create snapshots to avoid conflicts
so again in the streaming example that
we've seen many times of once the user
has performed the selection and the
streaming data is attempting to update
instead of updating in place we can just
create a new snapshot and updated in a
different place that way we avoid a
conflict altogether by writing to a
different version a more exotic /
involved application of this
visualization snapshot is to apply it to
a cross filter so here we have the user
selected the time of the day and it's
currently being processed this very busy
analyst wants to take another look at
what would happen if the filter is
additionally based on distance that
would essentially so the system
anticipates a right right conflicts and
splits into different view and similarly
if we add additional filter for arrival
delay that creates a new snapshot
because you could potentially create
conflict the good thing with this design
is that all of the different snapshots
could be executed in parallel and the
user is not prevented from performing
any interactions so this maps back to
sort sort of how multi version
concurrency control guarantees how we
don't have to block any of the read
and this also enables time travel which
some UI design for visualization have
argued to be a pretty good design and
lastly let's move on to the other part
of prevention which is communicating the
inconsistency we've already seen this
before so with blocking or adding labels
these are all ways of communicating
inconsistency and they're pretty good
and the only thing that we can improve
on on this is sort of making it easier
to program and the the sort of pitch
from the systems perspective to avoid
callback hells is that we can have some
sense of the global state so as to not
design too many callbacks and to check
for different states this doesn't do it
enough justice if you're interested
please refer to some of the work i will
linking to later so the idea is to deal
with inconsistency declaratively with
this sort of more system perspectives
and one project that we're currently
working on is to develop an API for the
front end state wrapping that into a
shim layer for consistency where the
user could just provide us with
interactions and request handlers and we
detect the conflict the user could
choose to sort of just acknowledge that
there are a lot of conflicts and know
how well their application is doing in
terms of like slow proofing or a
consistency proofing and to take that
step a bit further they can use this
information to prevent conflict or
communicate conflict again this projects
currently undergoing heavier
construction but will hopefully be ready
a few months time as computing and data
becomes more ubiquitous the distinction
between front-end and back-end data and
non data is dissolving I hope I was able
to convince you that consistency is
starting to become a real problem for
interactive data visualizations and some
other front-end problems there is some
marriage in taking a more data centric
lens to look at front end programming if
you're interesting this philosophy or
outlook there are a lot of related work
that's available to follow up on and
these slides will be made online somehow
and so with that thank you so much for
being here I'm looking forward to your
feedback please talk to me afterwards
thanks